alors là on a un gros esturgeon là je
pense qu'on est pas loin du 1 50 M60 les
premiers espèces d'esturgon elles sont
contemporaines des dinosaures elles ont
plus de 200 millions d'années ce poisson
super chelou il peut dépasser les 2 m de
long mais j'ai aussi découvert qu'il est
passé tout près de l'extinction dans les
années 70 son retour pourrait être un
exemple de ce qu'on peut faire pour
sauver des espèces il y avait encore des
populations au début du siècle dans les
grands fleuve d'Europe de l'Ouest les
populations elles ont chuté pour
différentes causes ce poisson c'est
l'esturgent européen il est notamment
connu parce que c'est l'une des espèces
dont les œufs permettent de faire le
caviar pour vous raconter comment des
scientifiques permettent son retour en
France mon collègue Florient est parti à
sa recherche dans l'estur de la Gironde
grâce à une interdiction totale de sa
pêche en 1982 et un plan de sauvegarde
européen il est aujourd'hui de retour il
s'est demandé pourquoi l'esturgeent
européens a failli disparaître qu'est-ce
qui permet de sauver ce poisson géant on
vous
explique donc là on effectue des traits
de chalu dans lesesuè de la giron on a
une vingtaine de zones où on peut
échantillonner les poissons c'est
important d'avoir des indicateurs de la
bonne survie de l'espèce aussi de l'état
de santé des animaux leur croissance
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont mangé et cetera ça
peut varier par rapport à des impacts
type augmentation des températures
augmentation de la salinité dans
lesesc en fait ça c'est un sondeur à une
certaine fréquence et on suspecte que
quand ça fait ce petit ce petit signal
ça peut être un esturgeon ou un conre
c'est un écho en fait de la vcine
atatoire en a un
alors là on a un gros escurgeon ça
juselle alors pour l'instant le plus
gros qu'on a eu c'est 1,80 mais
historiquement il y a des poissons
jusqu'à 3
m donc en fait l'espèce c'est ass per
sturio peu à peu depuis le 20e siècle
l'espèce elle elle a progressivement
disparu pour différentes raisons soit
par rapport à la dégradation de la
qualité des habitats notamment la mise
en place de gros barrages à la Valle des
grands fleuves qui empêcher la migration
par ailleurs c'était aussi une espèce
qui était intéressante bah à la fois
pour la chair et puis pour les œufs donc
pour le caviar le caviar en fait c'est
les futurs œufs donc ça se situe dans la
cavité abdominale il sont récoltés en
sacrifiant le poisson c'està-dire que on
ouvre le ventre et on enlève toutes les
gonades pour produire le
caviar là je prépare l'anesthésiant
donc c'est à base de
génol et j'arrête de parler parce qu'il
faut pas que je me trompe dans la
douse donc ça permet de l'endormir
doucement pour pas qu'il bouge pour
qu'il soit bien calme quand on le
manipule après tous les prélèvements
qu'on va faire comme les prélèvements
génétiques qu'on connait théoriquement
ses parents en faisant une analyse des
nageoires on va retrouver qui était ses
parents don quelle année il a été
et à quel stade au vu de sa taille et au
vu du faible nombre d'individus qui
seraiit sauvag qui serait né en en
1994 au vu de sa taille ça peut pas être
un individu
sauvage a priori il est pas marqué donc
ça veut dire que c'est un poisson qu'on
a lâché soit au stade larve soit au
stade juvénil de 3 mois entre 2007 et
2015 il y a eu plus d'un milli7
individus relâchés aux différentes
stades donc l'Arve 3 mois un an et puis
un petit peu plus donc on est passé de
d'une très faible population donc avec
que quelques rares géniteurs qui
pouvaient être observés en mer à une
population qui est peut-être entre 5 et
10000 individus les mâles ils sont pas
matures avant une douzaine d'années et
les FEM avant 16 ans il faut leur
laisser le temps d'arriver au moins à
cet âge pour se pour pour se reproduire
et il y a il y a beaucoup de pressions
qui peuvent impacter ces espèces longé
viv et de plus
migratrice donc 10h2 2 dans
l'anesthésique moi je par
sur8 je dirais 30 j'arrive 34 moins le
poids du
sac
pH c'est un gros individu là 34 kg ça fa
partie des plus gros qu'on a jusqu'à
maintenant mais c'est normal parce que
les les plus gros individus reviennent
je pense que c'est des individus de 2007
2008 donc individus qui partent en mer
il y a des individus qui restent sans
doute assez près dans la
girondbe et qui reviennent manger un
petit peu dans
l'estuire
parfait donc ça c'est une marque à
identifiant unique qui se mesure avec un
un
lecteur
voil
puis au niveau externe bah c'est un
identifiant qui est plus destiné s'il y
a une capture
accidentelle pour que le le la personne
qui va repêcher le poisson bah puisse
nous donner son son numéro la pêche est
interdite mais par contre il peut y
avoir la capture accidentelle en fait et
là les les pêcheurs doivent relâcher les
individus et les déclarer et en les
déclarant ils peuvent nous donner des
infos comme la longueur de
l'individu la localisation GPS du
poisson ce qui nous nous permet
compléter un petit peu les trajectoires
de vie de ces individus il est vraiment
en danger critique d'extinction donc il
est vraiment sur toutes les listes
rouges les directives
européennes convention de Bern
convention Spar donc il est vraiment au
maximum de ce qu'on peut faire en terme
de protection prend un petit bout de
nageoire
ici c'est pas quelque chose qui va le
gêner par la suite ça non ça vraiment
les nageoires ça repousse et puis c'est
un de lor c'est vraiment le bout de la
nageoire c'est un peu si comme si on
coupait un peu les ongles je pense qu'il
faut que tu te mettes de l'autre côté
ouais tu la tiens comme ça ouais tu la
tiens comme ça et ça pareil ça reste du
cartilage donc c'est pas douloureux ça
peut être un peu long à faire il sert à
lirelâge en fait comme sur les arbres il
y a des strip par exemple sur les trons
ou sur les écaille on peut lire l'âge là
c'est un poisson qui a pas d'écaille
donc on part sur une petite un morceau
de
structure osseuse qu'on monte à petit pr
après dans la résine et en fait on voit
l'esprit comme comme ce que vous pouvez
voir sur sur l'esprit des arbres ou sur
les autolites d'autres poissons et
au-delà nalanise d'age et ben on peut
aussi regarder un peu la microchimie
aussi de ces
structures pour en connaître plus sur
l'habitat des poissons donc là on les
devine mais il faut vraiment les monter
sous microscope pour voir
l'esprit
donc là on va le ou la relâcher euh
parce qu'il commence à être bien
réveillé
ok
ouais
nickel là on est au mois de septembre
donc je pense qu'il vient manger dans
l'estuire
et pour repartir un petit peu grossir
donc c'est un poisson qui
potentiellement peut revenir l'année
prochaineu que en bonne voie que tout le
monde a fait maximum de choses pour que
l'espèce soit soit saué mais ça ve pas
dire qu'il faut relâcher les effs
paruard donc il va falloir être patient
on croise les dos pour les de années qui
viennent mer reportage qui m'a vraiment
appris pas mal de trucs n'hésitez pas à
liker la vidéo si elle vous a plu ou à
nous dire ce que vous avez pensé de ce
reportage en commentaire dimanche
prochain à 11h je vous présenterai un
animal encore plus chelou et je vous dis
à
[Musique]
bientôt